nascar driver carl lawson capped off his
comeback season last month with his
first championship almost a year and a
half after it looked like his racing
career was over it was larson's first
full season after serving a suspension
for using a racial slur
thanks to the compassion and forgiveness
of one family he received a second
chance cbs news special correspondent
james brown shows us why larson is now
working to give back to the family who
stood by his side
kyle larson a year ago watched the race
from north carolina today he's a cub
series champion
when kyle larson claimed his first
nascar championship crown
[Music]
his winner's circle celebration featured
two very special guest
michelle and anthony martin are
co-founders of philadelphia's urban
youth racing school an organization that
connects young people of color with the
racing industry they remained steadfast
in their support of larson during his
tumultuous title run they're great
people and i'm and i'm very lucky to
have them in my life
in april 2020 larson used the n-word
while speaking with a white colleague on
headset during a live streamed virtual
race
you can't hear me
hey
wow
kyle you're talking to everyone but
larson's racing team fired him sponsors
dropped him and nascar suspended him for
six months but after a tough
conversation the martins stood by his
side you were very pointed in saying you
wanted to know who was the real
kyle larson
have you found out who the real kyle
larson is
i have i have
and
he is who i thought he was in the very
beginning meaning he was the same kid
that i met in 2017 who just happened to
make a mistake he needed help
to understand what he really did
michelle you also understand the
environment that we live in right now at
the public square we are a very divided
country absolutely
and as an african-american couple
canceled culture whatever you want to
call it we're looking at you and anthony
like why are you guys stepping out and
vouching
for this white racer
who used that vulgar word because you
know it was the right thing to do he
lost everything in the span of 24 hours
so when you think about that and you
think about
second chances and i think about the
students that i have here coming to the
racing school is a second chance when
you walk in our doors if you have a gpa
of a .7 which i've seen before 0.7
i give you a second chance i give you an
opportunity so it's kind of like if we
cancel
everyone we'll never know the greatness
that people have to offer we see this
car with a different body design since
the school opened its doors in 1998 the
martians have used their love of
motorsports to teach stem skills and
provide career guidance to young people
in philadelphia i was upset i'm not
going to lie william johnson is a
current student what kyle did was he
admitted he was wrong he admitted to his
mistakes and then he worked hard to fix
what he had done wrong well it's just
it's not a word that
i i'll ever use again i've learned so
much since then that i feel like
a lot of people i've heard you say in
the past now don't say it either so i
feel like they've learned from my
situation
and they've become better from it too
through all the adversity
it could seemingly stunt your ability to
perform with the gifts you have on the
track
what role did that play in terms of your
putting together a championship season i
think i'm a much more focused uh racer
now i think i've grown up both on and
off the racetrack from it all too what's
a champion to you i looked up to drivers
like jimmy johnson so just doing good
things in the community doing good
things off the racetrack i think that's
what makes a true champion he's doing
just that donating 100 thousand dollars
on a recent visit to the urban youth
racing school what did today mean to you
and anthony
you know at the core
kyle [ __ ] just really solidified what
the rest of our relationship moving
forward is going to look like i think
that when our students
understand the story and listen to this
story i really would want them to think
hey you know what one day somebody if
i merit it somebody will give me a
second chance that's what i hope that
the kids took away from it today
the great james brown joins us right now
good morning james good morning nate i
love how michelle is thinking if you
cancel everybody that made a mistake
there will be very few people standing
people deserve a second chance she's
like you no nonsense she can look you in
the eyes to your heart and she saw that
his heart was there which is why she
stood by him she said look i've got kids
in my class who are wearing um ankle
monitors yeah and if we're giving them a
second chance and selling a second why
can't i do the same here despite how
tough this issue is
at the public level